hi there Steve Kaufman here again to
talk about language learning and today I
want to talk about reading strategies as
an important part of language learning
an important part of motivation we know
that reading can be a very very powerful
way to learn vocabulary to get used to
the language stephen krashen talks about
free voluntary reading I'm a big
believer believer in reading when I have
dedicated learning time I read now not
everyone is motivated by an interest in
things that makes them want to read some
people are motivated by other things but
if you're interested in reading as a
major learning activity it's important
to keep the fires of your motivation
going now I'm gonna show you what I do
to do that but everybody has to find
their own motivation all right first of
all let's talk about a variety I think
it's important to have variety in one's
reading it's very easy as an independent
language learner to sort of lose your
motivation lose that fire get frustrated
feel you're not getting anywhere so I
like a variety that means that I
sometimes go over for the end time easy
texts that I have done before and I vary
that with more difficult more
challenging texts where I am picking up
more new words and where I'm usually
more interested because I'm discovering
new things now much of that activity of
course is done on my iPad where I can
access link and I can look up words and
in the case of Arabic where I have
trouble pronouncing new words I can hear
it pronounced in text-to-speech and all
of that is great but to make sure that I
keep my brain fresh and keep myself
motivated through a variety I have
introduced now 10-15 percent of my time
on Farsi which I'm very much at the
beginning of but it lets me struggle
with Farsi for a while and then I go
back to the Arabic which then seems a
little bit easier so there's that
variety not only easy
difficult text within Arabic but two
different languages one a major one a
minor another way of introducing variety
is to read on paper because again I did
a little bit of research on this but we
learn differently from a digital format
a screen than we do from something
that's written on paper and I don't
fully understand it but it appears that
in in terms of our retention we have a
better sense of an overall context when
reading from reading on paper but we can
sometimes pick out specific details of
information when reading on a screen I
am sure that the screen is selling
sending some impulses through my eyes to
my brain that are different from what
I'd get when reading on paper so at link
I have started printing out the stories
that I'm reading that I have read on the
screen where I have all this sort of
help I can look up meanings I can hear
them and then I struggle to read the
Arabic here on paper and it's a
different experience and I discover
things actually words that I didn't know
that I felt I knew because I was reading
them on the screen in Lync were had
access to the dictionary into the sound
and stuff like that so again I then do
this
and go back to the screen I can even
print out of course you can't see this
very well but I can print out my
vocabulary and rather than reading my
vocabulary in you know these sort of
activities that we have at link I
actually read them on paper so again I
vary the kind of activity that I am
doing I vary the the format in which I'm
reading another thing that I think is
important is oh yeah and I also do read
you know I'll flip through this book so
I'm actually getting information about
the Arabic language and I'm always keen
to read
I don't read the English in these
explanations but I read the you know if
this happens to be an Arabic verb then I
will read it now on paper which is good
discipline for me
and I'm gaining information about the
different forms of the verb which I see
in the text but again it's kind of
reinforced for me when I'm reading it in
this book similarly I have this book on
Farsi which isn't very good by the way I
one day I'll do a little thing on my
Icee meal Arabic which I thought was not
a very good book because the content is
not very natural I have also gone
through my higher ups Arabic and it's
not bad one of the things you find as
you read and you get used to reading and
you get used to reading in Arabic that
the script which seemed painfully small
the font at the beginning is getting a
little larger for me I have a little
easier time reading it but still it's
not as easy as reading on my iPad where
I can adjust the font size and I get
instantly the meaning of different words
and stuff so I did some of that you know
I have I bought this Persian verb book
which I've lived through and I will get
back to so I have a variety of resources
that I use some digital some on paper
and I think this variety improves the
efficiency of my learning
I'll also maintain my motivation another
thing you can do is because I you know
some people are interested to meet
people and talk I don't have that
opportunity although here in North
Vancouver as I've said the fact that my
doctor is from Iran and shopkeepers are
from Iran there is this motivation to
learn Farsi but my motivation for Arabic
is more sort of interest in the culture
of the history and so forth and so on so
I have books I didn't bring up the
history of the Arab peoples but I have a
book here about Baghdad which I'm going
to read but for whatever reason I
started reading this book Persian fire
and it is actually written like a novel
it's fascinating
and it talks about the Medes and the
Persians and then the Ionian Greeks and
Lydia and the Athenians and Sparta and
so you're in that world of 500 BC where
Persia is them the great Empire and the
various Greek city
States are fighting each other and I'm
right now at the point where the
Persians have laid waste to to Lydia no
tomb to Miletus which is this Ionian
city and the Athenians are now expecting
an attack from the Persians and trying
to organize their defence and so forth
so it's off through the language and of
course I did study Greek and I now the
Arab so not yet in the picture here
although undoubtedly lots of Arabic type
people were living in the area that was
dominated by the Persians and so reading
about the subject or about the history
about the culture is also a way to
maintain your motivation so just a brief
discussion of you know reading
strategies and the importance of variety
variety in terms of what you read Ramadi
in terms of the medium be it iPad iPhone
computer paper things that I print off
of Linc books that I might buy this
maintains some variety so that you don't
get bogged down I hope that is useful
and I look forward to your comments
thank you for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]